Hồi hồi suy chua nâng emy trình năng sáng lợn của bân cấp khá của tổng thống Mi đường nân trăm cho biết.
Tổng thống Trump đã phê duyên một kế hoài quân sự, nhằm vào Iran, nhưng đã tạm hãl lệnh tấn công để chờ sai,
tế ra ngưỡng mộ chức yêu cầu của các chiến tình hay không.
Theo một tiên, tổng thống Trump vẫn suy chỉ lập trường kinh giảm, yêu cầu Iran đồng hàng bú đu kiện và từ bỏ hoàn toàn truyền hảm nhăn.
Chúng khi đó, đường đơn giản cân quân thảo tin từ chính phủ Mi, giờ báo mục tấn công của thế giản dàn trong phản ngày tới.
Tìm Mi cũng đã tăng cường hình giản quân sự tại khu vực.
Một tầu khu chục thứ 3 đã tiến vào diễn Trung Hải.
Chúng khi nhóm tắc chiến tổng sân bay thứ 2 đang tiến đến biển nạt lập.
Lâu nếu không thảo nình đấy là biển phá phòng thủ, sau mừng rợ qua sân nhận định dựa giản dẻ này tạo lựa thế,
nếu Mi lựa trọng phương à tấn công.
Bây giờ Iran, lánh tủ tối cao ai gia tụi là Ali khâm nè tuyên bố, nước này sẽ không khó tục và tình báo mọi người của sự của Mi sẽ phải chả giả.
Trong trường hợp sảy ra tấn công, các sởi anh nhé phó đều được cho làm một tiêu tiêm năng hàng đầu của Mi.
Lý mi châu không mấy tỏ nó ngại.
Các ui đối ngoại AU cạnh báo, sự hiện diện của Mi khu tiền làm gút tiền hoa của sự đột.
Và kêu gọi các bên tiêm kiểm sải phá ngoại sao, thay vì theo tháng trắng thẳng.